une petite école en pleine campagne le
rêve des fouilles allait asphyxier par
la brume de sable actuelle pourtant les
petits écoliers de macumba sont
peut-être aussi exposés à une pollution
celle des résidus de pesticides dans les
airs alors pour savoir ce qu'ils
respirent concrètement ce capteur de
madininair y est installée récemment on
a une liste de 80 pesticides qui seront
analysés sur toute la france on a on a
quelques composer ce que c'est la
matinée comme le corps déconne on a
demandé d'ajouter cette piste est cette
substance et qui sera aussi analyser
pour la martinique et pour toutes les
régions
en réalité il y a très peu de chances de
retrouver des résidus de chlordécone
dans ces prélèvements
le pesticide n'étant pas volatile les
relevés seront effectués durant une
année
le résultat donneront une idée moyenne
des résidus de pesticides présents dans
l'air par tout en martinique à ce jour
de nombreuses craintes existent sur leur
potentiel conséquences sanitaires
mais rien n'est encore prouvé la grosse
problématique pour les pesticides dans
l'air c'est qu'il y avait eu un déficit
de connaissances lançait sa sortie en
octobre dernier un rapport montrant
qu'on avait très peu de connaissances
sur les pesticides dans l'air donc
l'objectif de cette étude c'est déjà
d'avoir une vision et ensuite de ce
qu'il ya dans l'air et ensuite de
pouvoir établir des normes parce que
pour l'instant même si on va mesurer des
choses c'est très difficile de comparer
avec des normes sanitaires
donc il ya tout un travail au niveau des
autorités sanitaires pour voir mettre en
place des normes si les prélèvements
relevé un macouba sont positifs cela
signifiera qu'il se mélangent dans nos
poumons aux particules fines de la brume
de sable et à l'hydrogène sulfuré dégagé
par les sargasses un mélange que les
scientifiques nomme l'effet cocktail
même s'il est peu documentée une chose
est sûre en france la pollution de l'air
causerait la mort de cinquante mille
personnes chaque année